Hey, welcome back to 40 Days of Holiness. So glad that you're here.
Today we're in 1 Thessalonians, right? One book of the Bible.
And in this book, we're going to see just a
remarkable story of a group of people.
The Apostle Paul came and planted this church in Thessalonica.
He came and preached there in Acts 17, and he preached for
three weeks, and then he got run out of town. All right?
So he didn't have a long time to develop them in holiness.
He didn't have a long time to teach them about all of the holiness that
God had provided for them. He was focused in, for those three weeks,
on teaching them of the beginnings of
salvation, of repentance from sin, and forgiveness of
guilt, and salvation by grace through faith.
So then he leaves, and he
sends back to them two letters, and one of them is 1 Thessalonians,
and that's where we are. Now first, let's just make sure that we look at the
scripture in 1 Thessalonians 1, and we come to the conclusion
of whether or not these people are saved. All right?
And I made a little word cloud here, actually.
I wrote down all the words that I found about them in 1 Thessalonians
1. And so I found words about the Thessalonians when Paul's
describing them.
I saw the words power and conviction, and they welcomed his word,
and they were saved, and there was love and hope and faith and joy from the
Holy Spirit, endurance. They turned from idols to serve the true
God. They were waiting for Christ's return. They were models.
Wow. Models to all the other Christians.
And they were welcoming him, and they had endurance,
and there's even more of those words in 1 Thessalonians chapter two
and three. Now,
since that's true, we can see that clearly these people were
really not just Christians, they were really doing well.
There was a lot of sincerity and powerful work of God in their life.
They were clearly saved. Which makes it very interesting when,
in chapter three, verse 10, Paul says, "I
am praying night and day
earnestly." So he uses all these, like all the time,
passionately is the idea. He's praying really, really powerful,
serious, sincere prayers. And he says, "I'm
praying that I might be able to come visit
you and perfect or complete that which
is lacking in your faith." To
fill up and supply what is lacking in your
faith. Now, this had to be an interesting moment for them when they
heard this
message from Paul, this letter was read to them.
I want you to imagine. I'm a basketball guy.
Maybe your sport's something different, but I want you to imagine if you
had the opportunity to be coached for three weeks by, let's say, Michael Jordan
or LeBron James or somebody like that, right?
And then a little while later, after they were gone,
they sent you a letter and said, "I am so excited to come back and
be with you again and complete that which is
lacking, perfect that, finish that work that is
lacking in your basketball game."
Well, now, if Michael Jordan or LeBron James writes something to you
like that,
I should probably pay attention to that, right?
I should zone in on that and say, "Wow, I wonder what's wrong with my game?
Let me figure this out." I should be passionate about and interested in finding
out where's the lack so I can make it up, right?
If the greatest basketball player of all time points something out, I should...
In the same way, when Paul writes to these
Thessalonian Christians and to you and I, as sincere believers, and
says, "Oh, I'm praying night and day earnestly.
This is serious business that I fix the gap,
that I finish out the rest of your faith, the rest of
what's lacking in your faith in Christ."
So he gets over a little bit further toward the end of the book.
He deals with some questions that they had and some confusion they had.
And then at the end of the book, he gets to a really, really fascinating
point. So in 1 Thessalonians
5:23 and 24,
something really interesting happens.
He switches into what's called the optative mood in
Greek. So it's like a wish mood, a longing,
a ugh, a groan to see something happen.
And he switches into that mood, and he says--
He starts praying for them, and he says, "May God
himself, the God of peace,
sanctify, make you holy, through and
through,"
or entirely, some translations say.
Either one of those is a really good translation. Entirely or through and through.
That's the word.
So he's crying out that God would make
these holy Christians completely holy.
Now, when is this going to happen? When should they expect it?
Is it going to be on their deathbed?
Is it going to be
right as the gates of heaven click behind their heels?
Is it going to be in some future purgatory?
What's going on here? Well,
here's a hint. He says, "I am praying that your
whole spirit and soul and body," which is the totality
of your personhood, right, everything about you, "would be
preserved
blameless
until the coming of the Lord Jesus Christ."
Now, I would just point out to you that that's really significant, particularly the
word preserved, because he's not saying that this is a
work that God's going to do at the very end of your life or
someday just before you enter heaven.
Click, there's something that happens in you that sanctifies you entirely
through and through. No, he's saying "I want to do this for you," and
then it is going to keep you. It is going to be a
preservative of the soul
that enables you to be established in such a way that your
life and your spirit and soul and body can be
preserved from that moment of your sanctification through
and through,
be preserved until
the return of Christ,
however long that might be.
Now, that's an incredible reality. That's an incredible promise.
This is something that isn't true now, but it can be.
And he says, "I pray God your whole spirit, soul, and body may be
preserved blameless until the coming of our Lord
Jesus Christ." So he's crying out
that their spirit, soul, and body be kept
until that day. Now, I want to give you one more verse, and that's
the last one in that chapter, one of the last ones.
He says,
"Faithful is the one who calls you."
Faithful is the one who calls you. Who calls you to
holiness? Who calls you to total sanctification?
Who calls you to being sanctified through and through and preserved blameless?
God does.
It's not Paul.
God's using Paul to do it, but it's not about him.
It's about the Father who has willed it, the
Son who has provided, and the Spirit who is able to put it into practice in our
lives. "Faithful is he who calls you, who also
will do it."
He will accomplish this. It is the will of the
Father that all his people be holy, that the
destination of our hearts and the state of our hearts match
the destination of God's universe.
Wow.
So I'm calling out to you, and I'm saying, the Father has promised
it. Will you not expect and
spiritually really hit the books, right, and lean in and say, "Oh,
God, teach me how. What do you need to do to make me holy through and
through, and preserve me, spirit, soul, and body?" Let's do that.
All right? I'll see you tomorrow.